good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
there's this moment in the cartoon
he-man and the Masters of the Universe
where the villain Skeletor says now it
turns out that Skeletor did not invent
this colloquialism but he did introduce
it to me and of course skeletor's plans
were always foiled by something he
didn't know but he was right about there
being a lot I don't know like there's a
lot about the present I'll never know
I'll never know what it's like to be
fluent in French or to play soccer
professionally or the mathematics
underlying quantum computing and I'll
never know almost everything about the
past because from the political
structure of the Indus Valley
Civilisation to what I ate for breakfast
on January 10th 2011 almost all of
history has gone unrecorded so we'll
never really know the answers to big
questions like why humans transition to
agriculture or the answers to small
questions like why prehistoric cave
paintings so rarely depicted human
figures we can make increasingly
informed speculations about the past and
those speculations can be productive and
interesting and even help deepen our
understanding of the past
but you'll never know and in that sense
the past is sort of like the future
because we can speculate about the
future and we can even model the future
in ways that can be super helpful but we
can't know like I will never know what
life is like for humans in the 22nd
century
here's the thing though even when it
comes to things we'll never know we have
to make guesses and in fact we make
guesses all the time and what we try to
do is make the best and most informed
guesses like when Sarah and I were
deciding to get married we couldn't know
what it would be like to live together
for decades or to raise children
together or to face loss together we
made the best guess we could and then
honestly we got very lucky or at least I
got very lucky and so whether I'm
deciding what to study in school or how
to spend an afternoon ultimately I'm
making a guess about the future and the
matrix I use to make those guesses has
recently been like obliterated which is
part of what I find so dizzying and
confounding about this historical moment
this is a slight tangent but when I try
to explain to people what uncontrolled
mental illness feels like for me I often
say it's like having to get out of bed
in the morning and get dressed and go
through my day while feeling that at
literally
every step the floor might collapse
beneath me I feel as if I cannot trust
the floor and that if I fall through it
it will be like that Emily Dickinson
poem and then a plank in reason broke
and I dropped down and down and hit a
world at every plunge anyway these days
it feels like the floor I count on to
always be there is less secure than it
used to be and like Skeletor really
could write a book about what we don't
know we don't know if surviving kovat 19
leads to long-term immunity and we don't
know the exact effectiveness of various
mitigation strategies and we don't know
how many people have had kovat 19 or how
many people have died of it like in the
2009 h1n1 flu pandemic there were 18,000
631 laboratory confirmed deaths but
later studies found that at least
150,000 people and perhaps as many as
half a million actually died from the
pandemic now we're doing a better job of
tracking kovat 19 deaths but our
statistics are still really incomplete
and so we don't know most of what we
need to know but there have been many
failures with kovat 19 failures of
preparation failures of political
leadership failures of the systems we
count on to distribute information and
goods and services but I would argue the
idea of expertise hasn't failed we're
just watching in real-time how it
happens which is that our species starts
out not even knowing there is a new
virus spreading among humans and then
over time learns the properties of that
virus and then eventually progressively
better strategies for containing it
we're already making better guesses
about what the future may look like and
how to make that future look less
catastrophic and over time through
shared expertise we will get better at
treating and preventing this disease
until one day someone writes a book
about what we didn't know but did
eventually find out Hank I'll see you on
Friday